whose book tv
next on real america
traces the history of the kkk from its
resurgence in 1915 inspired by the
silent film birth of a nation
through the post-world war ii years
the film includes scenes of ku klux klan
ceremonies and interviews with members
which viewers might find disturbing
this 45-minute film earned cbs reports
and producer david lowe a 1965 peabody
award
[Music]
driver of this car was mrs viola liutso
mother of five children 20 miles from
selma alabama on route 80 a red and
white sedan overtook her car several
shots were fired the driverless car
veered off the highway and came to a
stop at a cattle fence mrs lieutso was
dead
arrested and charged with murder were
three alleged members of the ku klux
klan one was tried and the jury was
unable to reach a verdict
this is an earthen dam the temporary
grave of three civil rights workers two
white one negro mickey schwerner andrew
goodman and james chaney beaten and shot
to death
among those indicted for this triple
slaying were six men identified as
members of the ku klux klan none has
been brought to trial
in this automobile reserve lieutenant
colonel lemuel penn was killed by a
shotgun blast while riding through
colbert georgia arrested for this crime
were four knights of the ku klux klan
two klansmen were tried and acquitted
in a few short months five murders 13
alleged members of the ku klux klan said
to be involved in the killings when such
an order is this
moves in and takes over the police power
you are completely at their mercy
and their atrocities and their violence
can be visited on anybody that disagrees
with them in any given situation
what started as a joke a hundred years
ago when a group of men donned bed
sheets for a romp has over the years
attracted to it persons charged with
acts of harassment intimidation and
violence throughout the south
even though the nation has been outraged
for many years the ku klux klan persists
with its bizarre ritual and trappings
but a hundred years is a long time for a
joke
cbs reports presents the ku klux klan
the invisible empire here is cbs news
correspondent charles kuralt
good evening
the ku klux klan is a secret
organization which for 100 years has
been allowed to exist in this country
virtually every president of the united
states in the past century has said the
clan has little regard for constituted
authority president johnson following
the murder of mrs leutzo in alabama
defined the ku klux klan as a hooded
society of bigots and warned klansmen to
get out of the clan and return to a
decent society before it is too late
after the president's warning the house
on american activities committee started
a full-scale investigation of the klan
and open hearings are scheduled for next
month
the hearings will present witnesses not
only clansmen but also victims of clan
activity however the committee will not
attempt to show the clan in action
for the next hour we will take a close
look at the ku klux klan from the inside
out examine its leadership its ritual
its secret initiation
its record of violence
first let us look at klansmen without
their robes
it is sunday the morning after a ku klux
klan meeting in durham north carolina
these men are members of the united
clans of america knights of the ku klux
klan one of the most exclusive
organizations in america
it excludes many protestants all roman
catholics jews negroes spanish americans
puerto ricans and anyone else who
according to the ku klux klan is not 100
pure american i don't hate [ __ ] man i
don't i don't i don't associate with
[ __ ] but on the other hand i don't
associate with common white trash or
jews or catholics if i can help it right
this is the grand dragon of the north
carolina realm of the united clans j
robert jones former sailor bricklayer
lightning rod salesman he now reportedly
rules over more than 50 claverns or
chapters and their 7 000 dues-paying
members
i think the [ __ ] has rights in this
country he should have equal rights but
separate rights it's worked for 100
years in the south and i think it will
work now but if you was the nicest fella
in the world and
and lyndon johnson said i had to
associate with you every day i tell
lyndon johnson to go straight to hell
because i would not associate with you
this is the grand console the late matt
murphy who until his recent death was
chief legal counsel of the united clans
his favorite targets were the negros
jews the federal reserve system and
international bankers
i had made speeches before the united
clans of america
and they were the only organization that
ever went on record after i had talked
for two solid hours
on the viciousness of the federal
reserve corporation and how it has built
the taxpayers and american citizens out
of all the money
and that great britain has removed the
bank from the international bankers and
their bank is back under the crown
action is nighthawk this is a nighthawk
of the united clans in north carolina a
nighthawk is responsible for the
security of a cleverness
well i've got a wife
five kids
i think that's enough reason i want them
to be
have a country to raise be raised up in
like i was
i wasn't forced to go to school with
[ __ ] i wasn't forced to eat with them
and i want them to have at least the
right that i had it's a disarmament this
is mr outlaw wherever jones goes mr
outlaw the grand clexter or guard is at
his side
in the group are the three defendants
indicted for the killing of mrs leutzo
eugene thomas
william eaton i don't have a one member
wilkins these men had little to say they
preferred listening to their counsel
matt murphy jr
i read in my history books that the
[ __ ] man the lego race was an inferior
race and that was a history that was
taught me when i was in school that
hadn't been too long ago they always
have been they always will be well where
do you think the money is coming from
behind the civil rights movement from
the communist party from the zionist
christ killing jews and i say christ
killing jews because they have not been
a flood since the since they crucified
christ and their relatives can be traced
back to the one that's running the
streets today
what about the role of the catholics in
this mr jones uh the reason callie
cannot get in this organization his
first allegiance is not to the united
states of america his first allegiance
is to the pope they believe that the
church should rule the government with
the pope at the head
and if they're right there's a bunch of
people in this country wrong
let me say this we have never had a drop
of blood spilled between a white man and
a black one in any town in north
carolina that we have the clan organized
right and we are doing our best to keep
down trouble
but my people are everybody in this
country is organized with the exception
of the white protestant gentiles your
[ __ ] have your knights of your naacp
in court along with your sorry white
trash you've got uh banaba risk for your
uh jewish people your knights of
columbus which is a secret fraternal
order as they say and nobody's ever
talked about investigating that which
they should
uh
in here but the white protestant gentile
the only hope the only salvation that
they have left in this united states
today is is the united claims of america
incorporated we've saved the south twice
or the clan has and it looks like we're
going to have to do it again
one important ku klux klan official was
not at this meeting the clan club or
chaplin but there was a clud in action
the night before
you got a bunch of people standing right
over here with a cameras and they're
used things like hey bubble they've got
enough backbone to get them a job and go
to work but there might be some good
ones in the crowd
i want to tell you fellas i'm just
telling you you fellas right over here
they'll print half of the story they got
enough backbone to tell the truth so
anybody that lives with the devil you're
going to die and go to hell without god
[Applause]
investigate them i live from 209 and go
to having you lexington north carolina
and my name is roy
and i'm not ashamed to be a
[Applause]
this is the classmate club in action the
preacher evangelist the hellfire speaker
the rabble rouser he entertains with a
mixture of comedy and christianity but
above all he preaches racial
do you think hatred is brought up to mix
the black and white together do you know
your horse won't mix with your cow your
dog won't mix with your home and you
tell me white people has got a mind and
can't paint no clear than that
listen friend
we need to turn to god we need to rake
up that god we had forefathers died to
give us freedom
our forefathers walked barefooted in the
snow and fought and died to give us
freedom and now here we set back because
we've got a dictator in the white house
a dictator and you sending your money
down out of bed and ain't willing to
stand up and be counted like a mineral
that takes a man to stand and be amazing
anybody can go down to [ __ ] town and
commit adultery with a [ __ ] but it
takes a christian a man to stand for god
amen let me call you farmers to attend
to a few things he raised homes
and you know when the old hog has a gang
of little pigs she'll try to protect
you'll know the dog when they have a
gang of pups they'll try to protect them
and you tell me you've got a gang of
white children running around in your
yard and you're going to stand by and
see them sold out to a bunch of [ __ ]
god help you to wake up and try to do
what god have you do
but take y'all
act like a decent person
and then if you don't want to do that
don't be a half-handed hypocrite don't
be one-sided go into [ __ ] town forget
about it
[Applause]
the clan was born 100 years ago in
pulaski tennessee as a six-member social
club
but six years later the clan had half a
million members and the burning cross
the clan trademark became a symbol of
the violence it used to keep the newly
freed negroes in their place
in 1915 dw griffith produced and
directed what has been called the first
great feature-length motion picture the
birth of a nation whose subject was the
ku klux klan today this film made 50
years ago is still shown to klansmen as
the classic example of what other
generations of southerners did to
protect white supremacy these are some
scenes from the birth of a nation
a chance witnessing of two white
children under a bed sheet scaring a
group of negro children as depicted as
the birth of the idea for the clan
the idea is successful robed and masked
klansmen are able to frighten the
negroes
[Music]
in a fight the negro sought for scaring
a white girl and causing her to jump
from a cliff to her death kills a white
man
[Music]
captured the killer is taken into the
woods and put on trial
the clan passes judgment
the culprit is killed and his body
deposited at the door of the lieutenant
governor
in the same year the birth of a nation
was first released a new leader rose to
head the clan william joseph simmons one
time salesman of ladies garters in this
rare newsreel film leads his followers
up stone mountain in georgia for the
first initiation ceremony of the
reincarnated clan
simmons added something new to the clan
uniform a stylized face mask which he
alone could wear
he also insisted the clan operate in
total secrecy
the clan's sinister power grew as new
recruits joined some through coercion
and its clandestine activities increased
in the first 14 months after world war
one 70 negroes were lynched 14 burned
in 1922 imperial wizard simmons could
not overcome intraclan difficulties and
was replaced by a dentist from dallas dr
hiram evans who inherited a depleted
treasury from simmons as well as his
title of imperial wizard
in 1923 evans established headquarters
in washington to be closer to congress
the clan's next target
the clan was so powerful in oregon in
1923 that it was able to elect the
president of the state senate and the
speaker of the house
in ohio clan supported candidates became
mayors of toledo akron columbus and
other cities
at the national democratic convention in
new york in 1924 it is estimated that at
least 350 delegates were klansmen and
they were responsible for the defeat of
governor alfred smith as the democratic
nominee
by 1925 the ku klux klan was big
business almost six million americans
now belong to the clan and the
organization was grossing 75 million
dollars a year
some 40 000 klansmen and clans women
crowded into washington on august 8 1925
to parade down pennsylvania avenue to
help the clan coffers a flag was used to
catch money thrown in by spectators
in the 1920s the imperial wizard of
indiana david c stephenson was indicted
on charges of assault and battery rape
mayhem kidnapping and murder and found
guilty
this scandal caused a sharp drop in klan
membership
in 1940 there was a mild flirtation
between the german-american bund the
believers in the master race and the ku
klux klan the believers in the supremacy
of the white race they joined up in a
rally at camp nordland new jersey
25 years later there is evidence that
clan nazi friendship is being revived
this year in houston texas gerald
walraven claiming membership in the
united clans knights of the ku klux klan
was interviewed by radio station ktrh
and was paid by check for his appearance
when the canceled check was returned to
the radio station it had been endorsed
by lincoln rockwell head of the american
nazi party with a swastika stamped
beneath his signature
in 1944 imperial wizard dr james h
colescott received a bill from the u.s
collector of internal revenue for
685 thousand dollars for the klan's back
taxes
unable to pay dr colescott disbanded the
clan
but four years later colescott's former
partner dr samuel greene reactivated the
clan and many new converts were
initiated into clandom motivated by a
desire to keep the negro in his place
at a rally in macon georgia imperial
wizard green defended the new clan
we don't hate the negro
god made him black
and he made us white
and you will find this laid out in the
11th chapter of genesis
in which he segregated the races
and we knowing that for 5 000 years the
white man has been the supreme race
we the knights of the peacock's clan
intend to keep it the white race
today the organization differs from the
past in that klansmen are willing to
appear in their robes and hoods in
daylight
with the advent of the civil rights
struggle the clan has become more
militant some groups have paramilitary
units such as this one in north carolina
grand dragon jones security guards are
trained to take care of anything that
might happen at clan rallies
the clan also sponsors softball teams
since softball can't be played in robes
kkk letters appear on the uniform to
remind the spectators that this team is
made up of 100 percent pure white
american protestant ball players
sometimes klansmen engage in more
bizarre sport
the letters kkk were carved with a pen
knife on the chest and stomach of this
man in houston texas after he had been
hanged by his knees from an oak tree and
flogged with a chain the attorney
general of alabama richmond flowers who
is currently investigating the ku klux
klan in his state told us the klan to me
as a group
primarily
of thugs
that would use the civil rights issue
to
foster an organization or a clan as they
are
and will take the law into their own
hands they have become more at least
more or less their own police power they
are a police group within themselves
dedicated to defiance of law
uh violence
they are as i have expressed it before
they are a hooded bunch of killers and
night riders and
uh floggers
that this nation and this state
has no use for whatsoever
the strength of the ku klux klan is
difficult to estimate among its many
secrets is the actual membership total
students of clan affairs say there are
at least 30 to 50 000 active members but
there are probably as many as a million
or more americans who are strongly
sympathetic to the aims of the clan and
who if pushed to a decision would join
the clan
when a 100 percent pure white american
citizen applies for membership his
application is carefully checked
if accepted he can then leave what the
clan calls the alien world and become a
member of the invisible empire
for the first time in clan history cbs
news cameras filmed part of a secret
initiation ceremony at a clevern in
georgia filming had to be done with
available light and the only parts of
the ritual we could not film were the
secret handshake the password by which
clansmen identify themselves to each
other and the secret oath of allegiance
to the imperial authority of the clan
this is the ceremony we filmed
nation
[Music]
five initiates appeared before an
exalted cyclops a cloakard club and
clygrap corresponding to a president
lecturer chaplain and secretary
the men were presented by the club card
and they had been checked out by the
clocan or investigating committee
on a makeshift altar before an
electrified cross i placed a sword
representing ancestral courage and a
flag the emblem of pure patriotism
an open bible is laid on the flag
a glass of water which is used to
consecrate the initiates completes the
symbolic array
[Music]
so
[Music]
a clarego or inner guard sits at the
door
on the other side is a clickster or
outer guard
the clocard and two assistants report to
the exalted
cyclops sir five men and waiting having
to do the qualifiers in our climate
journey through the mr cave request of
citizenship and invisible empire united
playing the knights of the ku klux klan
thanks for co-car junior assistant we'll
resume your attention we have you all
follow me and be proud
of your stand in silence and take heed
to a plan of prayer
god give us amen
men who can stand before you dental gog
and damage present flatter
tall men sun crowns who live above the
fog and cook during private thinking
for while the rabble with a thumb horn
greed their large professions and their
little bees mingle himself his pride
low freedom week wrong rule of land and
waiting justice league god give us men
right face
huh
lift hey
this is the eyes of scrutiny part of the
initiation ceremony clan members pass by
the initiates for one last searching
look
you may pay some
right hey
forward
in this room the initiates swear
allegiance to the clan above all things
the secrecy and ritual of these meetings
which seem almost laughable to the
outsider have a grimly serious purpose
because of its secrecy the clan can hold
sway over a community
when men are initiated into clandom in
ritual such as this one their neighbors
will not know they have become klansmen
if some of the initiates are policemen
or sheriff's deputies their fellow
officers will not know
if they are jurors their fellow jurors
will not know
under the cloak of this secrecy the clan
can take over positions of influence and
power
i beseech you therefore brethren by the
mercies of god that you present your
bodies a living sacrifice be ye
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that you may prove
what is that good and acceptable and
perfect will of god
we recognize our relation to the
government of the united states of
america the supremacy of its
constitution
the union of states thereon and the
constitutional laws thereof
and we shall ever be true in the
faithful maintenance of white supremacy
and will strangely oppose any compromise
thereof in any and all things
are you a native born white gentile
american citizen
yes do you believe in the attempt of the
christian religion
[Music]
do you esteem the united states of
american institutions above any other
government civil political or ethical in
the whole world yes
i'll let you be on your right
[Applause]
now let us pray
[Applause]
[Music]
and assuming if you haven't for sworn
faults to deceitfully and assuming
you're now on behalf of all kremlin
assemble welcome you to citizenship in
the invisible empire nicely the ku klux
klan
the five new klansmen are no longer part
of the alien world now they are members
of the invisible empire entitled to wear
the robe and the hood the proud
possessors of the secret handshake and
the secret password
and now they can attend clever meetings
and clan rallies such as this one in
dunn north carolina
[Applause]
a clan rally has many elements of a
carnival it's an outing for the family
children start attending these outdoor
meetings at an early age robes for the
youngsters are made by mothers and
follow the pattern of adult roads
rallies always have entertainers and
their material is plan tailored for the
audience this entertainer recites a poem
the saddest story ever told
when a white girl marries a [ __ ] the
son of light goes down and glaring
spotless then appear on her wedding gown
and white and black men stand against
while getting this strange rose and
mother they will wreck themselves and
damn each other's souls
three days and nights she felt blacklist
pressed smug against her own and on the
fault a troubled soul let alone right
and groan
and so i was dragging through my days
far from god's love and grace till now i
know no black man lives can take a white
man's place
[Applause]
the featured speaker is usually a
well-known personality at this rally it
was the late matt murphy jr imperial
consul or chief legal counsel of the
united plans
and i'll tell
this ask you what to do and tell them
to
you
what to do because they're about to pass
a bill out there then if you strike your
civil rights wake up it's a federal
offense and they'll hold you before a
federal court and take you to the most
favorable gala they can find and cut
your head over they can and when i say
cut your head off i mean i'll send you
the federal penitentiary that's the way
they are doing it that's the way they
call the shots so for god's sake get
your gospel and he doesn't do it elect
somebody
[Applause]
attraction matt murphy introduced the
three men indicted for the murder of
civil rights worker mrs viola leotzo mr
w eden
[Applause]
i will
[Applause]
and befitting the occasion of a ku klux
klan rally the three men were besieged
by autograph hunters
and they willingly obliged
clan members accused of crimes must be
dependent their consuls or attorneys
must be paid in addition money is
required for operating expenses and
leaders salaries which run as high as
fifteen hundred dollars a month the
invisible empire needs a treasury but
where the money comes from and how much
is a secret what is known is that
initiation fees are between 10 and 25
and yearly dues for assessments range
from three to fifteen dollars a
conservative estimate is that the clan
is a million dollar a year enterprise
the money comes from initiation fees
dues robe and hood sales individual
contributions and from what can be
raised by a clan club at a
[Applause]
a
rally
that's prosperous and you can afford to
give a thousand you can afford to pay
one of the men's salaries
there might be a business man there is
there may be some companies
that can write a check for one man's
year's salary
to do nothing but set up units
throughout north carolina whatever you
have
ten dollars
walk down with it will you do that
is there others
you know we ought to be able tonight we
are tonight to be able to come way on up
the ladder
thank you thank you
we're going to counsel
[Applause]
the men and women in robes receive
torches and the parade around the kuklos
or circle begins
um
[Applause]
good boy
[Music]
what you are watching 700 robed and
hooded men marching around a burning
cross
took place in the united states in 1965
[Music]
[Applause]
is
clan leaders are sensitive about the
reputation the clan has for intimidation
and violence in an attempt to erase this
image they have adopted a new policy
which in effect says look at us we are a
fraternal organization we have nothing
to hide
imperial wizards and grand dragons no
longer avoid the press
clan leaders sport crew cuts button-down
collars and well-tailored suits
the most publicized and best organized
plan leader is imperial wizard robert
shelton of the united clans knights of
the kkk
shelton spends much of his time in his
tuscaloosa alabama office constantly
listening to tape recordings of martin
luther king jr while he examines
pictures of civil rights demonstrators
those he can identify are circled and
filed shelton explains why
we have a division organization called
the kbi the clan bureau investigation
and i might add it it's pretty effective
we're able to uncover a lot of evidence
that other departments might miss
the clan says it does not advocate
intimidation harassment or violence that
it is a peaceful organization
let us take a look at some proven clan
activities
in the small community of grey georgia
the only movie theater in town permitted
negros to sit in the balcony the clan
decided this was not a healthy thing for
the white people and every friday night
50 carloads of robed klansmen circled
the theater today the movie house in
gray georgia is closed
a victory for the clan
further examples of clan intimidation
were uncovered in an injunction lawsuit
in the fifth circuit court of appeals in
new orleans the hearings revealed that
in bogalusa louisiana sometimes called
clan town usa
some of the city's estimated 1 000 clan
members were auxiliary policemen
the city attorney who is responsible for
prosecuting charges against klansmen
arrested for violence against civil
rights workers was himself identified as
a klansman
the powerful bogalusa clan moved this
year against radio station wbox whose
owner was one of a group which invited
former arkansas congressman brooks hayes
to make a speech in bogalusa on race
relations
klansmen made hundreds of anonymous
phone calls to the station sponsors the
effect was immediate 75 of the
commercials were canceled
wbox is still broadcasting but at a loss
although the clan says it has respect
for law and order there are records of
countless crimes which some klansmen
performed for reasons they deemed proper
judge daniel duke who has fought the
clan for 25 years in georgia tells how
the clan administered its own kind of
justice it have a
the
clock and committee or
the committee that administered the
floggings
want to get on one side of this man who
was doubled up
with his
wrist handcuffed to his
ankles who had been taken from his home
he thought by legal warfare
and who had unknown to him
been reported by someone to be
a labor organizer and
they equated that to communism and then
they equated that to race mixing and
they would usually equate that to say
some
jewish person was back of it and
a multiplicity of things anything that
appealed to hate
prejudice they'd take this man and they
would beat him unmercifully
the ku klux klan does not stop at
floggings
eight years ago in birmingham alabama a
group of klansmen committed the most
heinous crime short of murder as a
warning to civil rights leaders they
abducted this man and castrated him
they hit me in the back of the head
told me to lay down
and they all grabbed me
stretched me out but one stood on this
song and one stood on this one
and one
caught my leg
and spread it apart then he got help
from the other one and they spread my
leg apart
the boss ordered him to do your weight
and they went to cutting them
when they got through cutting me
they put turmeric on me
said i wouldn't holler
put them down to make you hate more
i don't believe they're human
but not only individuals suffer at the
hands of the clan sometimes whole cities
are victims
in one large city there is evidence that
clan inspired violence touched off one
of the most vicious racial riots in
recent history
the place was saint augustine florida
this klansman was primarily responsible
for what happened
reverend connie lynch is probably the
most effective rebel rouser and preacher
of bigotry the clan has to offer most
people would kill you if you put a
jersey bull in among their white face
herefords
they'd shoot you
but they tell me that i don't even have
the right to fight to protect the white
race let these black bucks come in they
said it was going to be settled in the
bedroom well i got some news for them
there may be some bedroom
cases all right but when the smoke
clears away there won't be no bedroom
cases
little rock oxford birmingham albany
georgia bogalusa louisiana connie lynch
was there
and when racial violence was predicted
for saint augustine florida connie lynch
went there too
negroes were trying to integrate the
bathing beaches and the florida advisory
committee to the u.s civil rights
commission warned that the city was
becoming a racial super bomb with a
short fuse
the tempo of violence increased rapidly
in saint augustine the clan paraded in
the streets unmindful of the rain
on the night of june 25 1964 the fuse
burned down and the racial bomb exploded
saint augustine was the scene of a
frightening riot scores of people were
injured 19 hospitalized
connie lynch had done his work
i spoke for the white people
the white people rallied behind it and
we kicked the living hell out of the
[ __ ] sent the outer town [ __ ] to
the hospital and out of the state put
back to their own hometowns where they
all have been and the [ __ ] in saint
augustine got quite back over [ __ ] town
where they belong
these examples of ku klux klan activity
are not unusual
for the past 100 years the invisible
empire this self-proclaimed second
national government has reserved to
itself police authority and the right to
correct what it considers wrong
although some klansmen have been
apprehended and tried for their crimes
the fact remains that the perpetrators
of more than 225
bombings and 1 000 acts of racial
violence reprisal and intimidation in
the last 10 years have not been arrested
the problem is that law enforcement
itself is often in the hands of
authorities who either belong to or
sympathize with the ku klux klan
the publisher of the atlanta
constitution ralph mcgill
explains why citizens are powerless to
protest in such situations in the small
community you too often find that the
sheriff is a member
or that the deputies are members
and the poor white man or more
particularly the poor negro in a small
community
he well knows a detection at all the law
isn't going to help him because the law
is more often than not in the clan or
sympathetic with it in the small
southern community
the clan is not a single strongly
organized group it is composed of
splinter groups fighting each other for
new members and new territory
on memorial day weekend robert shelton's
chief rival james venable head of the
national knights of the kkk took his
clan north to a site 25 miles from
cincinnati ohio
both venable and shelton believed the
whites in the north worried about negro
civil rights demands in their own
communities are ready to embrace the
plan
this was the first open clan rally in
ohio in more than 30 years
the fact that the clan is getting bolder
was demonstrated by the site which was
selected right alongside super highway
75
clan robes many of which had been stored
away for years were put out for an error
since the building of a cross for the
clan ritual requires skill out of
staters volunteered to hammer the cross
pieces wrap the burlap carefully
and then soak their handiwork with a
mixture of gasoline and motor oil a half
gallon of gasoline and five pounds of
oil for every foot of the cross
the clan added a new touch to attract
crowds a skydiving show with parachute
jumpers releasing clan flags and then
landing on clan blessed land
the northernmost penetration of the clan
took place last month near cleveland
ohio
all cars headed for the rally were
searched for weapons and police
confiscated high-powered rifles shotguns
and pistols
there were the usual preparations
including the raising of the cross
at a nearby restaurant men lined up to
get applications for membership in
imperial wizard venables knights of the
ku klux klan
that evening 25 men and women kept at a
safe distance picketed the meeting
[Applause]
the burning of the cross was the high
point of this rally only 21 miles from
cleveland
does the invisible empire have a right
to continue its activities either in the
north or the south
in our democracy freedom of speech must
be accorded this organization klansmen
have a right to meet and wear uniforms
if the clan is a fraternal order it
should enjoy the privileges of other
orders
but the truth is that among all such
organizations only the clan has a
history of violence
lawmakers have not ignored the clan 22
states have passed laws prohibiting the
wearing of masks in public
and 52 southern communities have
outlawed masks and cross burnings
but even these laws have been
ineffective klansmen can still legally
wear masks and burn crosses on private
property they still intimidate and
harass citizens
now the office of the attorney general
is working on new anti-clan legislation
mission to congress attorney general
katzenbach was asked what form this
legislation might take
well i think it could take a
number of forms
one would be to
follow the analogy with respect to the
communist party
and to seek
full disclosure of their membership and
a
listing
of the clan and its members
and its officers as a sort of glare of
publicity
another
approach
perhaps a better approach
would be to
follow the pattern of the existing laws
but
to expand their scope of federal
jurisdiction under them and to increase
the penalties under them
so that the federal government could get
a more deep involvement
we put up with a clan for a hundred
years in this country how long is it
going to take
for us to
see the end of the clan
i don't know when we'll see the end of
the clan
i think the end of the clan is
any kind of an effective organization of
any sort at all is
within sight i doubt that
the clan is going to be a very effective
force anywhere 10 years from now
earlier in this program we showed
reverend roy woodle a clan club in
action
a few days ago woodle quit the united
clans incorporated last week at his home
near lexington north carolina we asked
him why
well if people would just check the
record and see this now who is leading
the clan and what are they and what do
they stand for
that would be a logical question
so take in the individual what if he be
in the clan or out check the leadership
say for example we have people with the
painter contractors as far as i know
failures
we have people with insurance agents as
far as i know failures
we have people with concrete business as
far as i know failures and such as that
just uh
failed out and flunked out couldn't
promote leadership and uh just lost out
everything they had and then well and
they couldn't find nothing else to do as
the fellow said they made him a clans
leader
at every clan meeting reverend whittle
they go around and collect money what
happens to that money where does it go
well as far as we know it all finds its
way in the pockets of leaders now if you
know when else when i doubt myself as an
individual
uh
i just can't tell you now we know
that they do take up money every
rally now we know that the news knows it
uh everybody there knows that they pass
the buckets around and they do take up
money
but far as we know
that's the end of it uh we don't have no
uh record or nothing else as far as i
know now somebody else may know
something i don't know but all we know
is people riding around lives in their
motel drives their cadillac eats the rib
eye steak and laugh at the poor people
as they go by whatever happens to the ku
klux klan will not finally happen in
washington
it will happen in those small towns of
the south whose natural spirit of
generosity and justice have been damped
and whose leaders have fallen silent if
the clan prospers it will draw its
strength from such communities
if the clan falls
it will be because one man and then
another in such places
have made up their own minds that a free
society cannot coexist
with an invisible empire
this is charles kuralt
good night
[Music]
my
[Music]
the ku klux klan the invisible empire
was filmed and edited by the staff of
cbs reports under the supervision and
control of cbs news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign